Mein Name ist Peter Stroh. Können Sie bitte Ihren Nachnamen, wo ich da bin?
Stroh wird geschrieben Siegfried Theodor Richard Otto Heinrich.
Stroh, Herr Stroh.
Ja, gut.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 28 Jahre alt.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,76 m groß.
Wie schwer sind Sie?
Du sagst.
Ich bin circa 89 kg.
Wer ist Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihr Hausarzt?
Mein Hausarzt heißt Doktor Walter.
Doktor Walter. Danke für die Information.
Herr Stroh, was wird Sie zu uns, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ja, und zwar, ich bin vor ungefähr 1,5 Stunden vorher mit dem Fahrrad gestürzt.
Und ich wurde eben gerade mit dem RTV gebracht.
Und ich habe Schmerzen im Bereich meiner linken Schulter und im Bereich meinen linken Brustkorps.
Okay, Brustkorps.
Okay, Sie haben in Ihren linken Schulter und Brustkorps zu machen.
Okay.
Wie ist es zu dem Unfall gekommen?
Und zwar die Straße war nass, es regnet draußen aktuell.
Und wo bin ich ausgerutscht und gestürzt?
Okay.
Wohin sind Sie?
Auf meiner linken Seite.
Deswegen tut auch meine linke Schulter und meine linke Rippen oder linke Brustkorps.
Okay, haben Sie Schwellung oder Beleutung gemerkt?
Nein.
Haben Sie Farbe veranderen auf Ihre Haut?
Nein, ich habe keine Farbveränderung gemerkt.
Okay.
Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf eine Schmerzkala?
Wobei 1 l der Schmerz, 10 und 1 l der Schmerz.
Ich würde sagen ungefähr 7.
7.
Wie können Sie Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben?
Dumf oder Drucken?
Das ist die Schmerz.
Ich würde sagen, es ist ein dummer Schmerz.
Mein Brustkorb ist ein stechender Schmerz.
Ich habe besondere Schmerzen, wenn ich atme.
Wenn ich tief atme, habe ich Probleme.
Okay.
Sind die Schmerzen schlimmer geworden?
Schlimmer würde ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Haben Sie diese Schwierigkeiten beim Atmen?
Nein, ich habe sie am Anfang auch.
Ja, seit dem Umfall.
Ich kann atmen, ich habe keine Probleme,
aber wenn ich tief einatme, hauszen möchte, habe ich Probleme.
Sie haben Schmerzen.
Entstehen Sie Schmerzen irgendwo aus?
Nein, würde ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Haben Sie andere Verlisten in anderen Körpertauschen?
Auf einer Wunde.
Nein, meine Haut ist überall geschlossen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Misserfindigkeit oder Kreppel zum Beispiel in Ihrem Arm?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Ihre Schulter gut bewegt?
Könnten Sie Ihre Schulter gut bewegen?
Ja, bei Bewegung tut es wie aber weh.
Zum Beispiel, wenn ich meinen Arm ganz hochheben möchte, habe ich Schmerzen.
Ich habe Schmerzen.
Die Wirklichkeit ist schmerzbedingt eingeschränkt.
Okay.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihre Haut schwer linken eine kalte oder warme als die andere?
Nein, es ist nicht. Es ist kein Temperaturunterschied.
Hatten Sie früher einen Beschwerden oder einen Umfall?
Nein.
In jedem Sinnbereich hatte ich bis jetzt keine Verletzung gehabt.
Okay.
Und Sie haben auch Schmerzen in Ihren Burus.
Und diese Schmerzen strahlen auch mit aus?
Ja, weiß ich nicht.
Es tut mir halt weh, im Bereich meiner unteren Rippen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Luftnot oder Herzrasen?
Herzrasen?
Nein, ich fühle mich nicht.
Und Luftnot, wenn ich nicht viel tief atmen muss, habe ich keine Luftnot.
Nein, ich habe keine Luftnot.
Okay, danke.
Haben Sie eine Schmerz?
Nein, ich habe keine Luftnot.
Haben Sie Schlafprobleme?
Nein.
Hat sich Ihre Gewicht in letzter Zeit verandert?
Nein, nicht wesentlich.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit oder Durst?
Wie gelah ich immer?
Normal.
Leiden Sie unter Fieber, Stufros, Nachschweiß?
Nein, leide ich nicht.
Okay, haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen, Stullgang?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Jetzt möchte ich über Ihre Vorerkrankungen wissen.
Haben Sie krönliche Krankheit, Bluthochdruck, Blutkack-Krankheit?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarfmedikamenten?
Nein, bei Bedarf, weil ich Profänein, wenn ich mal Schmerzen habe, war, die letzte Zeit habe ich nichts eingenommen.
Okay, sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Ja, wo ich 15 Jahre alt war, wurde ich an Blindam operiert.
15 Jahre?
Okay, gab es eine Komplikation nach der Appressions?
Nein, fertig, alles komplikationslos.
Okay, sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja.
War Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Nein.
Okay, jetzt komme ich zu Ihrer Familienanalyse.
Gibt es eine krönliche Krankheit bei Ihren Eltern, Großeltern, Bluthochdruck, Blutzuckerkrankheit, Krebs oder Ännihe?
Ich weiß nicht, was Sie für Erkrankungen haben.
Ich weiß nur, dass mein Vater irgendwas mit Herz-Rhythmestörung hat.
Irgendwelche Medizin nimmt.
Und meine Mutter nimmt Schilddrühse-Tablette, hat sie mir gesagt gehabt.
Weswegen?
Ich sage nicht.
Hat sie Schilddrühse unter Funktion oder über Funktion wissen Sie?
Nein, weiß ich nicht.
Haben Sie Schwester?
Die Schilddrühse wurde bei ihr operiert.
Operiert?
Und Ihre Schilddrühse wurde einstatt?
Entfernt, ja, zum größten Teil.
Ich weiß noch, dass Schilddrühse ein bisschen drin ist.
Ah, okay.
Weiß ich nicht genau.
Vielleicht gab es eine Knoten in Ihrer Schilddrühse.
Ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie Geschwester?
Ja, ich habe einen Bruder.
Ist er gesund?
Ja, so, was ich weiß, ist er gesund.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Okay.
Sind Sie lebig oder verheiratet?
Nein, ich bin ledig.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich studiere Lehramt.
Wie bitte, was studieren Sie?
Lehramt.
Okay.
Und lebe Sie allein oder mit Ihrer Familie?
Ich lebe alleine, ja.
Und haben Sie Stress bei der Studie?
Nein.
Ist alles okay?
Studium hat mit mir Stress.
Ja, so, haben Sie Allergie oder Unverträglichkeit?
Ja, Unverträglichkeit nicht, dass ich wüsste, Allergie, Polnallergie.
Im Frühjahr habe ich Probleme.
Okay. Wie äußert sich diese Allergie?
Indem meine Augen rot werden und meine Nase läuft.
Oder wird dicht.
Nehmen Sie Medikamente?
Spray oder Toilette?
Nein, ich hatte früher, ganz früher hatte ich öfters mal
irgendwelche Präparate genommen.
Wieder essen die.
Da habe ich vergessen.
Aber länger nicht mehr.
Sie brauchen keine.
Nein, es ist jetzt nicht so stark.
Okay, herztro.
Ich habe keine weitere Fragen.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Fragen an Sie, ja.
Was habe ich denn? Wie geht es denn weiter?
Was ist mit mir? Können Sie mir helfen?
Natürlich, wir sind für Sie da.
Zuerst muss ich Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Ich muss Ihre Schultern und Ihre Brust gucken und abtasten.
Und möchte ich ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Wie rundkern von Ihren Schultern und Ihren Brust.
Dann werde ich Ihren Fahrrad mit meinem Oberarzt besprechen.
Und dann komme ich zurück und teile Ihnen mit, was Sie tun.
Okay, danke.
Jetzt bleiben Sie hier, kommen Sie und körperlich untersuchen.
Danke schön.
Ich habe ein Kollege, der noch andere Fragen.
Ich möchte eine Frage, zwei Fragen stellen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie voll Genf haben.
Genf sind ja.
Auch Tetanus.
Tetanus habe ich auch, ja.
Okay.
Bei der Unfall haben Sie eine Helmshuss getragen.
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Ich habe auch eine Frage.
Haben Sie an Ihre ausgestreckte Arm gestürzt?
Oder war Ihre Arm ausgestreckt?
An meinem Körper.
Okay, zweite Frage.
Haben Sie Oberbauchschmerzen?
Ja, kann ich nicht beurteilen.
Mein unterer Rippen tut mir weh.
Ja, okay.
Nach der Unfall haben Sie die Toilette gegangen.
Sind Sie gegangen? Nein.
Sind Sie gegangen?
Nein, das war nur eine Stunde.
Seitdem musste ich noch nicht.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Haben Sie das bewusst sein nach oder vor dem Unfall verloren?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Danke.
Können Sie Ihre Unterarm und Fingern gut benutzen und bewegen?
Ja, das ist möglich.
Aber Sie haben gesagt, bei der Bewegung?
Ich kann bewegen, aber im Herzen ist es eingeschränkt.
Haben Sie eine Fehlstellung bemerkt?
Fehlstellung? Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Noch von einem nicht gefragt?
Ja, ich habe die Begründung.
Stimmt, die Analyse bezüglich genussmittel wurde nicht gefragt.
Haben Sie Husten?
Nein, aktuell nicht.
Was meine ich? Sie aktuell nicht?
Jetzt nicht.
Also, seitdem hatte ich keinen Husten, davor auch nicht.
Aktuell nicht.
Ob noch entsteht, werden wir noch sehen.
Danke schön. Ich denke, alle Fragen gestellt.
Ich denke auch.
Können wir als Alsatzgeschichte anfangen?
Ja.
Guten Abend, Herr Opensarzt.
Ich möchte Ihnen einen Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie eine Saison?
Ja, bitte schön.
Es geht um Herr Peter Straubuck.
Er ist 28 Jahre alt, 1,78 m groß, 69 kg schwer.
Er stammt 89 kg schwer.
Er stammt bei uns, wegen einer halben Stunde,
nach dem Umfang vor.
Können Sie das verstehen?
Nein, das ist nicht gut.
Er stammt bei uns, wegen einer halben Stunde, nach dem Umfang.
Darf ich eine Frage eingreifen?
Ja, bitte.
Der Patient sagt, der Patient wurde mit dem RTV gekommen.
Ja, mitgebracht.
Der Patient wurde bei uns, wegen einer halben Stunde,
nach dem Umfang aufgetreten.
Er stammt bei Schurka und Torax, links und links.
Ich kann nicht aufhören.
Er stammt bei uns, wegen einer halben Stunde, nach dem Umfang.
Er hat v.a. einen Unfall vorges salah,
nach dem Unfall,
hatte er Schmerzen,
lent Jungkook,
mit dem När Guerrero
Er könnte ihre Schulter nicht gut bewegen.
Er habe Bewegungseinschreckungen in ihrer linken Seite.
Er hat darüber hinaus berichtet, dass er Schmerzen und Dispneum beim Tippatmung habe.
Die Fragen der Parästhesie, Schwellen und Hautverperberungen wurden verleicht.
Die Interstate League von Ziblin, der 10 auf eine Schmerze kam.
Die Schmerz-Charakteristik war in seiner Schulter und in seiner Brust.
Die Schmerzen wurden nicht verleicht.
Er hat keine anderen Verletzungen auf eine Wunde in anderen Körperteilen.
Er hat keine Tachycardie.
Als besetterter Anamnese hatte er keine Probleme.
Er wurde mit 15 Jahren eine Appendeptomie durchgeführt.
Besüglich der Medikamente nahm er den Ibuprofen bei Bedarf.
Er hatte Polenallergie, die allerergie äußert sich,
Renitis und Conjunktivitis.
Laut der Familienanamnese hatte er die Erfahrt,
die Erfahrt von Störungen und Medikamente entgegenzutragen.
Die Mutter wurde durchgeführt.
Der Patient hatte keine Diagnose.
Er hatte einen gesunden Bruder.
Er war ledig und studierte in England.
Er lebt allein.
Ich habe Genusmüchte nicht gefragt,
weil die körperliche Antarsäfte wieder fragen.
Ich habe einen Verdach auf Schulterdyslokasson.
Er hatte keine Fehlstellung.
Er hatte eine Schulterprällung.
Er hatte einen Kollegen gefragt.
Er hatte keine Prällung.
Er hatte eine Dislokation.
Er hatte eine Struktur.
Er hatte eine Diagnose.
Er hatte eine Repinfraktur.
Er hatte eine Struktur.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Die Kollegen haben gefragt, dass es keine Ausstrahlung gibt.
Es gibt andere Fragen.
Das ist eine Ausstrahlung.
Normalerweise machen wir die Ausstrahlung.
Wir machen eine Anamnese.
Wir machen eine Ausstrahlung.
Er hat eine radio-Faktor.
Noch eine Frage?
Wenn man auf dem Torax-Röntgen für Pynomotorax einverdacht hat, muss man erst mal Nadel, Aspiration oder direkt Torax-Speed CT durchführen.
Wenn man den verdacht hat, dann würde man eher einen CT durchführen, damit sie genauer sehen, was da los ist.
Wenn es ein Neumotorax ist, ist es nicht maximal oder minimal.
Wenn man an der Apikalin-Spitze der Lunge nur 1 cm neu ist, würde man den Patienten zur Beobachtung behalten und nicht nach Hause schicken.
Dann kann man am folgetag noch mal Röntgen-Kontrollen machen.
Aber in der Regel wird meistens ein Torax gemacht, damit man genau sieht, weil man im Röntgen sieht man nicht alles genau, wie groß der Ausmaß ist.
Wenn der Ausmaß klein ist, lässt man das, beobachtet man und macht eine Verlaufskontrolle.
Wenn ein Pynomotorax schon ziemlich groß ist, macht man trotzdem einen CT Torax, damit man den Trauma sieht in der Lunge.
Anschließend legt man eine Torax-Trainage rein.
Wenn man Pynomotorax hat, dann Pynomotorax.
Wenn man Pension Pynomotorax hat, dann Pension Pynomotorax.
Direkt Typ Toro-Kostüm.
Wenn er ein Pynomotorax hat, würde man trotzdem einen CT machen.
Also wenn er keine Dyspenö hat oder nach Rechtsverschiebung der Mediastin um hat.
Es kann ja in Tielfunktion sein, dass das immer schlimmer wird.
Wenn er keine große Dyspenö hat, würde man erst einen CT machen und dann die Drenage reinlegen.
Wenn er natürlich sehr dyspenöig Atemnot hat und so weiter, würde man direkt eine der Drenage reinlegen.
Aber dafür ist Zeit wichtig. Es kommt darauf an, wie der Patient sich fühlt.
Danke schön.